foreign
[Music]
the public school system gets a lot of
criticism for grooming and
indoctrinating children and for good
reason it's guilty in both counts but
perhaps the greatest problem the
greatest problem with the public school
system one's certainly not unrelated to
the first two issues that I just
mentioned is that it makes people Dumber
you know Americans are actually becoming
Dumber over time this has been
objectively observed and the public
school system is largely to blame for
this intellectual decline it must be to
blame for it is the education system it
is the system we have come up with to
educate people and mass and if people
are getting Dumber that that is always
going to be an indictment first and
foremost on that education system
this week provides us with an example
another example to illustrate the entire
scope of this problem indoctrination
intellectual Decline and how the two are
linked so this comes to us from a group
called The skeptic research team which
published a report that begins with this
introduction quote
for decades in the U.S and particularly
in the last few years journalists and
intellectuals have suggested that white
people are socially or morally deviant
Time Magazine For example published the
claim that white supremacy is the
foundational principle of the culture in
the U.S preventing non-whites from
having perfect hair perfect clothes
perfect grades or regarded as a perfect
employee and colleague
in 2020 the Smithsonian National Museum
of African-American history and culture
claimed rational thinking and hard work
our white supremacist ideals that
oppress non-white people in a recent
opinion editorial Savala Nolan the
executive director of the center for
social justice at UC Berkeley School of
Law
said white people disappoint me they
frustrate me they make me sad meanwhile
books describing the immorality of white
people such as cast how to be an
anti-racist and white fragility have all
soared to the top of the New York Times
bestseller list given these opinions in
this report we ask what does the public
really think about the apparent
immorality of white people
so that's what they're trying to explore
and to come up with an answer to that
question they conducted a study and they
asked respondents a series of questions
the answers to all of the questions were
quite concerning but I just want to
focus on one this is one of the
questions they asked
they ask various groups of people how
much they agree with the following
statement
and the statement is this
prior to the arrival of the European
settlers Native American slash
indigenous tribes lived in peace and
harmony
that was that was a statement let's see
how the answers break down along various
demographic lines the the majority of
those who self-identified as liberals
agreed with this statement 71 of those
who call themselves a very liberal
agreed with it 59 of political moderates
agreed to some extent with a statement
that native tribes lived in peace and
Harmony while even self-identified
identified conservatives and even very
conservative people agreed at a rate of
nearly 50 percent
look at the question along racial lines
we see that 75 percent of black
respondents agreed with 20 strongly
agreeing 63 percent of Hispanics agreed
along with 45 percent of whites the
generational breakdown gives us similar
percentages gen Z agreed at a rate of 71
percent for Millennials at 65 percent
Gen X it's 57 and Boomers was 41 percent
so all in all we see that
huge percentages of Americans believe
that the tribal people who lived here
before first contact with Europeans were
Angelic peaceful creatures who did not
know war or Strife or violence
this this entire hemisphere was a place
of love and peace and kindness and all
the tribes sat together around the fire
holding hands and singing songs of
togetherness
basically these people think that
Disney's Pocahontas was a documentary
they probably even believe that the
natives could talk to trees and animals
um that that appears to be the
prevailing point of view
thanks in large part to the public
school system because this is what
public school system basically teaches
now what can we say about all this
well first we must say that these people
are wrong for the record stupendously
breathtakingly wrong
I shouldn't need to clarify or explain
this but apparently I do native tribes
did not live in harmony and they
certainly didn't believe didn't live in
peace unless we're spelling peace
p-i-e-c-e I mean they did live or at
least die in pieces after getting hacked
apart dismembered scalped by their
enemies so if you mean peace in that
sense you would be sort of correct but
that's not what it's meant in this
context
president Trump recently issued a
warning from his Mar-A-Lago home quote
our currency is crashing and will soon
no longer be the world standard which
will be our greatest defeat frankly in
200 years there are three reasons the
central banks are dumping the US dollar
inflation deficit spending and our
insurmountable national debt the fact is
there is one asset that has withstood
famine Wars and political and economic
upheaval dating back to Biblical times
and that is gold I've bought gold from
Birch gold in preparation for uncertain
Economic Times and you can trust them
too you can own gold in a tax sheltered
retirement account with the help of
Birch gold that's right Birch gold will
help you convert an existing Ira or 401K
maybe from a previous employer into an
IRA in Gold the best part is you don't
pay a penny out of pocket when
currencies fail gold is a safe haven how
much more time does the Dollar have you
can protect your savings with gold Birch
gold is an A plus rating with a Better
Business Bureau thousands of happy
customers you can text Walsh to find out
why at
989898 and get your free info kit on
gold again text Walsh to 98989
picture if you will the perfect Summer
Night the warm breeze on your face as
you Lounge in your favorite chair
outside the grill sizzling with Juicy
Burgers the aroma of the food is
irresistible your mouth Waters as you
wait for it to be cooked to Perfection
now imagine with this perfect summer
night would look like if you went to
turn on the grill and your propane tank
is empty it's a tragedy and that's where
my friends at cinch come in and they can
save the day and avert tragedy cinch is
a propane grill tank Home Delivery
Service they deliver propane tanks right
to your door cinch delivers on your
schedule doesn't require any long-term
commitment or subscription plus delivery
is completely contactless which means
you don't have to wait around at home
you can track the order on the Cinch app
from anywhere whether you're grilling
for the sweet baby gang camping with
your family lighting up your fire pit on
a cold summer night whatever it is
cinches propane delivery service ensures
that you have the fuel you need to make
the most of every moment and every night
go online to cinch.com or download their
app to order new customers can get their
first tank exchange for just ten dollars
with promo code walls that's
c-ynch.com promo code calls this is a
limit time offer and you must live
within a cinched service area to redeem
it so visit cinch.com offer for details
these pull respondents think that native
tribes existed in a state of perfect
kinship and tranquility
if they had a disagreement they would
resolve it I suppose with sternly worded
letters
which actually wouldn't have been
possible anyway because native tribes
never invented a written language or the
wheel for that matter
and there wasn't much kinship or
Tranquility either on the contrary these
tribes existed in a state of constant
Warfare they fought all the time they
didn't just have wars you know they
wasn't they had a war
and then a period of relative peace it
didn't work that way instead they were
always at War they were always fighting
and and this is an important Point too
the fighting was more brutal more
barbaric more deadly than the kind of
warfare that Europeans and other
civilized people of the time engaged in
and here I'm not just referring to the
fact that many native tribes scalped
dismembered and sometimes ate their
enemies or the fact that civilizations
like the Aztecs captured prisoners by
the thousands and then cut their still
beating hearts out of their chests as
human sacrifices that's partly what I'm
referring to but that's not the full
story
the other thing that made tribal Warfare
so uniquely brutal and this is something
that Lawrence Keeley explains in in
depth in his book War before
civilization which is worth reading if
you haven't
is that tribes that they didn't they
didn't fight pitched battles okay these
were not
formal engagements on the battlefield
which especially at the time among
European countries that's what war meant
like they meet on a battlefield and they
uh charge towards each other and they
try to kill each other
among native tribes instead they sent
raiding parties and often at night
and simply slaughtered entire tribes
because there's no battle it's just like
we're they're going to show up in the
middle of the night and uh when when the
other side is not armed not ready and
kill everybody that's what they did
men who were captured would would not be
held as prisoners of War they would be
murdered on the spot or tortured and
then murdered women and children were
often killed as well or else they were
taken as slaves and I'm not I'm not
describing random rare exceptions or
isolated incidents here this is how the
native tribes conducted themselves is
what life was like
for centuries all across the hemisphere
before Europeans made contact it was a
brutal violent bloodthirsty place
now this is where the guilty
self-loathing modern American quickly
responds oh okay but that doesn't excuse
all the violence that white people
committed against indigenous people
but the point is not that we're making
excuses
although in fact it does excuse at least
some of the violence
because the point is that is that the
first settlers that came here they
didn't all come with a Sinister plan to
wipe out the native inhabitants in many
cases they landed on these Shores and
they were met with violence
which they then responded to in
self-defense
and you also have to see it from and I
know that we're not allowed to say this
if we could see it from their
perspective which is very hard to do
500 years later
but from their perspective they land
here they encounter people in loincloths
or fully naked who don't have a written
language don't even have the wheel are
living three thousand years in the past
from their perspective and then they see
brutality
unlike anything they'd ever witnessed in
their lives or could even imagine
okay like can you imagine actually
seeing someone get their heart cut out
of their chest while they're still alive
and so put it look can you just try to
think of it from their perspective for a
moment they come here they don't know
what they're going to get into they
don't know you know they don't know
anything it's like they don't have the
internet
um
they show up they encounter these people
these primitive people
they see barbarism cannibalism uh Hearts
being ripped out of chest dismemberments
scalping
and they arrive at certain conclusions
about the people that they see doing
this
conclusions that are we going to say
were totally unreasonable
one of the conclusions that they arrive
at is that is that well we need to be
like this these people are a threat to
us
well that is that an unreasonable
conclusion from their perspective 500
years ago
but this is not simply about assigning a
blame that's not the question more
importantly this is about understanding
history not just understanding one
historical event but understanding
history in general understanding the
history of the world and of humanity
the people who believe in the noble
savage myth are confused about that
period of History they're blinded by
their white guilt or their hatred of
white people but what's perhaps even
more troubling is that they have
apparently no grasp on the general
course of history which means they have
no grasp on Humanity on human nature
and if they don't understand history and
they don't understand human nature then
they don't understand themselves these
people are clueless at the deepest
levels
in an effort to take all the sins of
mankind sin shared by all and place them
entirely at the feet of the white man
they end up sanitizing history into
Oblivion
they neuter it they turn it into a
cartoon
and while they demonize white people in
many ways the non-whites fare even worse
because this cartoonish version of
native culture it may succeed in turning
native people into victims
but also it also makes them boring and
lame and devoid of any identity aside
from their victimhood
the truth is that native culture and
there there wasn't one native culture
but hundreds these were Warrior cultures
they were Fierce and battle-hearted
people
yes they engage in the most abhorrent
kinds of brutality but that doesn't make
them all cartoon villains any more than
Europeans who also engage in brutality
were cartoon villains they were simply
people who lived in a different time
governed by a very different set of
rules
and who had very different assumptions
and presuppositions about the world
it is important to understand that if
you want to understand anything about
history
and that is why the noble savage myth
that so many Americans who've been
mentally corrupted by the school system
by the media
uh is today canceled hey YouTube thanks
for listening to the show if you'd like
access to my full show with no ads you
should go to dailywire.com and use promo
code Walsh to get two months free on all
annual plans see you there